yannick trudel
vous êtes en vedette dans la série les
mecs fait sensation sur tou.tv et on
vous voit dans cette série là en train
de faire du spinning
mais dans la vie de tous les jours c'est
là qu'on se trouve oui vous avez weeks
peu d'énergie
j'accepte un type e s la réalité à ce
niveau là qui est un beau clin d'oeil et
ça m'a fait plaisir mais oui
effectivement ce fait sept ans que j'ai
ouvert ce studio là et j'en suis très
fier c'est un stand laïcité que les mecs
ça parle de god à la cinquantaine ils
vivent des problèmes de la cinquantaine
il a plus de la quarantaine il ya la
crise de la cinquantaine pour vous en
tant que médicament vient le triste dans
50 ans
mais moi c'est un peu une jacques darras
pour être honnête j'ai pilé cinquantaine
un peu comme las calles dans un bar à
trois hommes ouais ça me répète ce la
scor
c'est comme un courrier dans une
discothèque noir quant à 20 ans on ne
fait plus la gorge et ben en fait partie
de la game et enfin devant faire partie
de la gang pour moins longtemps
les familles sont plus gros et les
limbes cette fois plus d'eau que ça
prenne comme un jour avant semble vous
mettez de oui vous êtes un petit gars du
plateau mont royal
vous avez fait vos études au cégep de
saint-hyacinthe en âge mais à cette
époque là il y avait nos membres à tout
est gris galuchat voilà c'est tout il
accepte mais vous qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé parce que cet impôt a récemment
facile de personnes étaient à l'époque
lol moi c'est un concours de
circonstance de devenir comédien ce
n'est pas un rêve d'enfance j'avais pas
fait d'impro secondaire j'avais vu
pratiquement pas de théâtre c'est une
fille qui était en secondaire 5 avec moi
qui m'a dit je m'adresse si tu me
donneras dessus la réplique je veux
passer la gestion des écoles de théâtre
j'ai trouvé son intrigant puis je me
suis dit ah tiens je vais appliquer mais
aussi en même temps pêche avec trop
pourquoi faire avec le sujet et j'ai été
acceptée elle malheureux
non et j'ai découvert le métier à
travers la formation et j'ai découvert
que j'avais un certain talent en étant
lorsque j'allais au que la fed pour il
unis jugent qu'il allait se faire une
petite idée sourit les divers ennuis aux
etats-unis la série game gosse va
changer votre cause y compris moi je
veux le truc je l'arcep ce cas là on
quitte le québec les bacs à laçage
l'aise kaboom barca beau salaire
de fait la patente sauf que l'année
avant que j'ai également gauche c'était
vraiment difficile et j'étais tout le
temps sur le bord de l'eau chez de
l'archet de l'archer jeu très bien pour
une mini dépression et d'autres pleurent
et maman bébé leur écoute tu peux
revenir à montréal
vos personnes qui te force à être révélé
l'homme qui j'avais pris la décision qui
m'a vraiment fait du bien je me suis dis
à ma fight si je n'ai pas un signe
concret de la vie je m'en retourne à
montréal
ce programme qu'elle est légale et il
était le sien concret game goff dix
jours avant ma femme vous en donnerons
j'ai eu je le dis ce que j'ai obtenu le
round 10 jours avant ma famille à ma
femme je m'en retourner à montréal ce
n'est pas une blague
ce pêcheur et une mauvaise copie 28
lollipops des ridicules ait lollipops
gilmore girls est un des plus grandes
séries de télé américaine eut cette
saison est devenu une vedette
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être fait
d'être à nouveau la porte est tout le
temps là
peut-être serez-vous mais bon quand le
show est arrivé j'avais 30 ans oui j'en
ai plus profité de ce que tu peux tu
imaginer d'en pêtre les par des billes
qu'est ce que le match ne baisse pas
mais je sais pas si quelqu'un dans ta
tête mais bon c'est une ville d'excès
jeu on était quand tu es dans un show
qui est le succès de guillaume august
invités au cours d'une grosse d'invités
aux amis s'étaient invités dans toutes
les grappes actif active jeune femme à
être inclus dans un groupe de gens que
j'ai admiré toute ma vie par tom pyatt
jones colonies et puis aussi parce qu on
a beaucoup parlé de votre méga succès
aux états unis mais est ce que ça a pu
nuire à votre carrière ou québec est ce
que vous sentez que les jette un peu
plus raide sans vous appeler pour vous
offrir aussi belle et la perception des
gens
du métier je pense que c'était à celle
on l'appellera pas ça l'intéresse propos
il ya une carrière aux états unis
maintenant à venir faire un show à
montréal ou alors la même mais aussi son
propos offrir le même salaire alors que
je suis évidemment très conscients des
salaires ici et si j'avais fait ce
métier là pour l'argent
j'avais vraiment choisi mauvais métier
parce que le métier de comédien c'est
très rencontre mais riche et encore
moins au québec
je pense que là les gens du métier
commence à réaliser que je suis très
intéressé travailler ici comme toujours
il ya les cruisers merci beaucoup merci